[APPLAUSE]
AVERY*SUNSHINE: Y'all all right?
Did you all have a
good time with me?
Make some noise for
the other artists.
I love you all.
That was what you
call a power set.
Put your hands together
if you can, y'all.
I'm gonna do a little bit.
[MUSIC - AVERY*SUNSHINE,
"ALL IN MY HEAD"]
AVERY*SUNSHINE: So now you
know this part right here.
If you know it, come
one and say it with me.
[MUSIC - AVERY*SUNSHINE,
"SWEET LOVE"]
AVERY*SUNSHINE: Have you all
had a good time with me tonight?
[CHEERS]
AVERY*SUNSHINE: I need you to
get up on your feet, y'all.
Put your hands together.
If you're shining,
make some noise!
[CHEERS]
AVERY*SUNSHINE: Tell
somebody, I'm shining.
Say I'm shining!
Now I need you to do this--
it's a symbol of unity.
Before we go, I just need you
to do something real simple.
It's something real easy, OK?
Because we're all
unified, right?
I need you to say, [SINGING]
A-V-E-R-Y Sunshine.
Oh, y'all didn't catch it?
What is it?
AUDIENCE: [SINGING]
A-V-E-R-Y Sunshine.
AVERY*SUNSHINE: Oh
you know, I love you.
I ain't leaving tonight.
They're gonna have to
turn the lights out.
Say it again, say
it again, say it.
AUDIENCE: [SINGING] A-V-E-R-Y--
AVERY*SUNSHINE: Y'all
better sing harmony.
AUDIENCE: [SINGING] Sunshine.
AVERY*SUNSHINE: Say it again.
Say it again.
Yay!
[MUSIC - AVERY*SUNSHINE,
"ALL IN MY HEAD"]
AVERY*SUNSHINE:
Y'all keep shining.
Y'all keep loving.
Thank you so much,
Ryan and Google!
[APPLAUSE]
AVERY*SUNSHINE: Y'all
are absolutely wonderful.
And I'm blowing everybody
sugar right now.
[KISSES] I love you
all and good night.
[MUSIC - AVERY*SUNSHINE,
"ALL IN MY HEAD"]
[APPLAUSE]